how fitting that the first event
following Susan house mystic quest
through the exponentially reverberant
strata of the archive be Joshua
Beckman's lecture on the porous pneus of
the basic unit of litter of this
literary universe the book a discourse
on how this object efficaciously
breathes its contents into the
atmosphere inspires the imagination and
certainly resonates with me as someone
who daily inhales the rich humise of
Houghton's holdings on my subterranean
walks through its numerous rows of
subjects languages and temporalities but
i will let mr. Beckman articulate the
particulars of his compelling image and
instead limit myself to saying just a
little grace to open the evening written
by one of our patron saints of the
library Jorge Luis Borges a book is a
thing among things a volume lost among
the volumes that populate the
indifferent universe until it meets its
reader the person destined for its
symbols when that occurs is that
singular emotion called Beauty Charles
Wright publisher of wave books
established the Bagley right lecture
series on poetry in order to provide
leading poets with the opportunity to
explore subjects of deep personal
interest and to create lasting works of
criticism and poetics that will help
current practitioners in the art of
poetry along with scholars and general
readers to more fully understand poetry
as it is written and read in our time
Joshua Beckman was born in New Haven
Connecticut he is the author of nine
books including take it shake your time
has come and collaborations with Matthew
roar Anthony McCann and John Beecham he
is an editor wave books and has
translated numerous works of poetry and
prose including micrograms by Andrade 5
meters of poems by Oquendo Lima
and poker by tomorrow moon which was a
finalist for the pen America poetry and
translation award his most recent book
the inside of an apple was a finalist
for the Los Angeles Times Book Prize he
lives in Seattle in New York please join
me in welcoming him
Thanks okay but before I get started I
would like to say a little about the
display downstairs I know some of you
have gotten a chance to see it but if
you haven't afterward I think you can go
down and see it tonight I'll talk mostly
about books and various poetic relations
to the book and while nothing down there
is a book exactly my hope tonight is
simply to try and understand the book as
one of many possible points in the life
of a poem so one of the pieces included
is a letter of Emily Dickinson Dickinson
famously chose not to publish and while
that is often represented as a kind of
isolation one sees throughout her life
an attachment to the poem as not only a
private endeavor but a shared object and
one which allows a kind of continuation
of the process of writing while in the
very act of expanding the public life of
the poem I've also included some poems
by Walt Whitman he wrote his poems wrote
and rewrote that single book of human
social presence and his constant changes
and re articulations of self and self in
the world are part of what makes us feel
near to him today the anxiety and effort
of all of that for him feels a part of
the exuberance and grandiosity the fear
and belief that still seems to vibrate
with something alive it is our
connection to him his being in the world
all body and self and cosmos that seems
to pour out when we encounter any small
part of him I stand in the dark with
drooping eyes by the worst suffering and
the most Restless I pass my hands
soothingly to and fro
Oh a few inches from them the Restless
sink in their beds they fitfully sleep
now i pierce the darkness new beings
appear the earth recedes from me into
the night I saw that it was beautiful
and I see that what is not the earth is
beautiful I go from bedside to bedside I
sleep close with the other sleepers each
in turn I dream in my dream all the
dreams of the other dreamers and i
become the other dreamers the sense that
one is here with us once we have known
them as we encounter them is as real and
fictitious as daily life and I've
included a piece by John Burroughs the
popular american naturalist and friend
of Whitman's they attended Lincoln's
inaugural together and burrows among
other things was the first to write a
biography of Whitman for which it turns
out Whitman secretly wrote a great deal
of it himself making it in ways I
imagine more hand less accurate and
everything here everything I will
discuss is in some way about friendship
friendship being at the core of not only
human affinity but all human relation
and expression Emerson in his essay on
display downstairs describes friendship
as the masterpiece of nature and it
strikes me as well as the substance of
human life making with its presence and
absence realities of all the realities
we encounter so I had this idea to talk
about a walk or really to try and take
you all on a walk I feel at times the
kind of attention one is open to on a
walk is not dissimilar to the kind of
attention that can guide one through a
poem by a walk
I mean something between a stroll and a
hike that movement into the outside
world with the hope of encountering it
the kind of walk which if someone asked
what you were doing you would say I'm
going for a walk that kind of walk you
feel things you notice things your body
is activated and engaged it is
constantly making intuitive in sensual
decisions you see something and look at
it or you see something and move around
it you hear and smell and touch
sometimes you wander off with your mind
and you are very much far away from the
actual physical world you are moving
through sometimes you are taken by
something a scrap of paper on the ground
or an animal or anything and it draws
you toward it draws your attention
toward and then mostly on you continue
with your walk parts of it elevating and
meaningfulness and parts of it floating
away almost completely unnoticed and
when I think about reading a poem when I
read a poem I say it aloud even when I'm
reading it to myself and then I move
through it the saying it aloud which is
hearing and speaking at the same time
feels to me like the guided and unguided
aspects of a walk and in many ways poems
are the temporary things that occupy the
spans of time it takes to see them or
hear them or read them the walk with the
endless mystery of its uncontrolled an
unfolding perspective can feel like the
poem while we easily recognize their
stable characteristics we can feel
especially in the acts of deeply
encountering them some aspects of the
accumulated moments of poems experienced
those moments inside the actual words on
the page without you and now made alive
as
full presence reading the poem aloud
mostly just keeping going and taking
things in as it is red one knows one is
missing something and one knows one is
accessing something as well my idea with
the poem is that it is to be experienced
I remember reading Robert Louis
Stevenson often when I'm reading I will
gather the books around sometimes on the
kitchen table or other tables in the
house and keep them together so that
even just moving by them excites some
idea or memory little connections
knocked against you during your day one
is reminded almost sensually of the
things those books are when walking back
and forth by them it's like a memory
holding the peripheral meanings that
swirl around it elevated by the
structure of its central concerns
identified or not and I was reading
Thoreau too so there were all the
Thoreau books and Stevenson books on my
kitchen table and I read this in
stevenson the woods by night all their
uncanny effect are not rightly to be
understood until you can compare them
with the woods by day and when I read it
I instantly remembered Thoreau having
said earlier that week in his journals
the journals in which he is often
documenting his night walks through
concord that one does not know the day
until they have walked at night and when
I remembered Stevenson and then I
remembered Stevenson saying of Thoreau
that he was dull and priggish and
unfriendly
and not having ever met him one gets the
distinct impression that he is just fine
not ever having met him and so here they
are together on my table saying not
surprisingly seemingly opposite things
one that you don't know the day until
you walk at night and the other that you
don't know the night until you walk it
day and I kept thinking that now at
least for me those things were basically
the same thing years after they are gone
years after there is nothing they can
really do about it I have put them
together and think fondly of how similar
they are look I thought they both enjoy
walking at night thinking about the two
of them I imagine this would be a good
idea for a talk on books and that I had
come to believe is what I was trying to
do thorough constantly writing journals
of his daily experience taking and
forming from those journals his books
almost like cuttings from a plant to be
given away to go grow in other people's
homes and Stevenson who made formed
things from the imagination to go
activate the imaginations of others so
giving and playful both struggling with
ideas of place and home one traveling
constantly the other notably still and
both dying at 44 leaving behind the
uninhibited refuse of their committed
literary lives I would think of the
writers theirselves present in their
books there are similarities and
differences just right out there for me
to sort of endless the engaging one
basic thought of the book is as I
continued them their lives reanimated in
their public and their private selves
presented
so vigorously in print and sort of
multiplying in the attentions to them
and while this idea felt like it could
be a real response to time and the
solidity of the object it felt so
strange pairing the two of them up and
making them do that as if just because
they're on my table they were they had
to talk there are these fantastic
stories from the 18th century about the
lives and communications of books their
poems really about every part of a book
animated and talking to every other part
the covers to each other the bookplate
complaining to its contents about where
it has ended up or the poem itself
calling to be set free from the confines
of the boards holding the pages in or
the other conversations of books with
each other like Swift's battle of the
books them interacting on the shelves
and speaking with each other introducing
each other berating each other ancient
and modern tomes bickering over the
respect or lack of respect one is given
or deserves the moral of the story of
all the books beginning to speak to each
other is usually that in no case will it
result in them getting along
and this is blamed naturally on the
character of the reader on the readers
inherent disregard for the differences
in the books acquired to have so many
disparate efforts brought together to
encourage so many unlikely relationships
or at least encounters and the ability
to unbalance seems at the center of the
experience of life with books the
visions and ways each conjure there are
different tones and languages their
voices and the places they bring us the
places they want to go and so I thought
that if I was going to talk about books
maybe I should just take you on a walk
but on a walk through a library and have
each book sort of do the explaining for
itself and then I started thinking about
which library thinking about the
different types of libraries and how
books come together in them not just
what happens when they do but how they
end up where they are it's hard to talk
about one library without wanting to
talk about all of them and which one
would i choose and then I thought not to
take that walk but just to list and
present all the various different kinds
of libraries the public ones gathered
and arranged systematically by many
people over years and years the private
ones in individual homes constructed if
constructed intuitively over a single
lifetime and other ones like the
temporary ones you take away on a trip
the books one might throw in a bag for a
walk or in the trunk of a car I think of
Joshua Slocum sailing alone around the
world in the 1890s rigging up his boat
to keep moving and it's sailing on while
he went below deck to his little library
and read Moby Dick or the imaginative
libraries like the one that
rose over time between two friends made
up of the books they actually share but
also the ones they talk and think about
to the ones they associate with each
other or the private library inside of
the public one the books you go back to
over and over again and take out and how
they become yours it's so rare that a
book is out there on its own removed
from the others I can't really consider
books without considering these social
structures the spaces they make for us
but the more and but the more I thought
and wrote about that the further away it
seemed I was getting from the objects I
wanted to talk about Thomas Gray
notoriously wrote in books that belong
to anyone if he saw a mistake or
something he thought could use
clarifying or expounding upon and it
seems that libraries throughout England
and as far afield as right here are
still full of books that are full of his
scribbled notes and I thought I could
just write about him poet private
scholar bibliophile friend correspondent
whose private communications inspired
countless public ones whose descriptions
of the lace lake district are as
responsible as any other work for the
appreciation and enthusiasm of the
romantics for the place having written
just a handful of poems living the life
of the book but making few and he was
considered to have stopped his literary
output altogether the decade before his
death but the reality was that he was
writing in the margins of his books most
notably his copy of linnaeus as natural
systems a catalogue of living things
writing on every bare spot of it writing
and drawing pictures
of notes in English and Latin that
spanned the mundane to the poetic
practical and imaginative at one moment
describing the inspiring forceful
movements of the wings of a bird in
flight and the next describing how tasty
or salty it was and now I was just
getting desperate I had tried so many
things I went back and read the
description of the lecture I was to give
there wasn't to walk anywhere to be
found I said I would talk about the
intimate and communal experiences of
poetry and how they relate to the book
as an object as well as the private
library and the porous experience of the
book in real and imagined space oh no
was I really going to try and do that
what did it mean I knew what it meant
but would I just go and enact it or
would I take it apart and explain for me
the porous experience of the book was
simple it was the only way I had come to
understand it I would be eating a
sandwich or I would be sweating and the
oils in my skin would get onto the page
or i would go to grab a book I hadn't
gone to in a while and the dust would
come off it straight into my lungs or I
would be walking down the street and the
experience of some poem i had read
earlier would real merge in my walking
self or maybe even in my words i would
say something and the voice of someone
else or even stranger the impulse of
someone else would come out of me mixed
with what felt like my own and my
experience of the real actual book my
experience of touching and holding it
and having the poem close to me and my
experience of the lives of the poems and
poets that accompany me when I'm away
from their books blends completely with
myself as a person a reader a poet the
poorest nasai meant that things move in
and out of you fluidly and not exactly
effortlessly but not in a controlled way
either it's an openness that's what a
poor is and to think of what the poems i
was reading were doing and how they were
entering me and how aspects of them
would come out of me at times it is easy
to think of it as a feelings and
understandings you read a poem and its
understandings of things enter you as
understandings or feelings you feel that
in the experience of reading a poem and
now that feeling is in you
capable of being had and out into the
world as feelings are sometimes sent out
word but really the porous pneus was
about all the slight things the waves
and aspects of the poems that enter you
unnoticed or at least unidentified and
that's the closeness to the poem I think
so there I was just trying to explain
the title and I had the idea that
spending all of this time trying to
figure out a way to make a lecture about
something like books in the poet's life
was just too much and had made me
scattered an oblivious to the basic
experience of standing up in front of a
group of people and telling them about
something I couldn't after all stand up
and tell you everything I've been
thinking and yet being with books sort
of encouraged just that in Ruskin's
elements of drawing he berates the
indulgent parent who gives the child too
many books so that instead of being
forced to find the meaning within the
child can sort of browse and gather to
their imaginations content and that a
few books regardless of how good they
are are a better inspiration to the
youngster all I can really say is that
it is probably sensible to heed this
warning but I have not so sort and
browse I continue to do I had been
reading for years and I had been making
notes for this lecture for years I had a
pile of paper scraps and every time I
would have an idea or a line would come
to me I would scribble it down and every
time I would find something in a book I
was reading I would stick into it a
little piece of paper writing down some
particular quote or noting what
imaginative place it brought me to I was
reading and thinking not certain where I
was going with anything and for most of
the time
I wasn't really sure what the lectures
would even be about and in fact that
kind of helped me keep going I'm a poet
and I'm the kind of poet who really
doesn't know what he is doing when he is
doing it I make poems to find out what
they say not to make them say what I
want in fact if I know where on going I
rarely ever want to go there and would
never actually end up there anyway and
for a while I thought the lecture should
be about that the experience of not
knowing of moving inside the poem to
find out what it will be of letting the
book be formed by the unknowing creation
and not responding to it with any
prepared set of needs and expectations
for 10 years I worked on a project I was
gathering quotations on birdsong I
started to do it with a friend but he
drifted away almost immediately and I
just kept doing it I would find in
whatever it was I was reading a car or a
call or an explanation of sound and I
would take that quote and copy it down
I'm not really sure why I was doing it
birdsong seemed appealing in English it
felt that first I think like a kind of
getting to know the poet's I loved the
poet's I loved loving birdsong Dickinson
through her window and Coleridge out in
the hills I think I found their joy and
excitement joyous and exciting and
wanted whatever that was and that is
basically what i got that seemingly
random and impromptu appearance of birds
in our lives and how that was mimicked
in my reading i would be reading along
and then there on the wire of some
narrative a bird would land and start
to sing for a while this project was the
most enjoyable thing and I wasn't just
enjoying myself I was getting something
done that's my inner response to
pleasure and leisure there I was no
matter what I was reading building some
archive to what end I really didn't know
but something was being made something
was growing then after a while I would
find myself waiting not exactly skimming
a book but waiting for that moment I
could take something from it
birdwatching is in many ways not about
the birds but about their surroundings
it feels while you are doing it more
like you are trying to act like a bird
there you are still there your head
moving quickly and anxiously in relation
to some slight sound or movement you
stare at trees and bushes and the sky
most of the time and only rarely see
another bird the joy i think is being in
the space they are in and imagining in
at least some way you are attending to
the things they attend to so that
eventually when you do see the elegant
trogan you feel a bit like the two of
you have something in common but with
the books it began to feel to tactical
like I was staring at them and only
really interested in when the birds
appeared and so eventually I just
stopped I imagine there are plenty of
reasons for tactical reading for the
kind of reading that has you getting
something you already know you want but
that for me is the complete antithesis
of art so that if what I'm reading is
art treating it that way is not only
undermining the work I'm looking at it
is making me less absorbent and capable
of big experience and feeling I remember
I wanted to start the talk with a brief
description of a scene in a film by
Jacques Tati
where he he's a French film actor think
a shy well mannered Charlie Chaplin and
he lackadaisically wandering through the
market and up to his attic apartment by
way of every possible stairwell and
through every clothesline doorway and
tight corner only to get there to open a
window and what he was doing was opening
the window so that a bit of light
reflected off it and went across the
courtyard to land on a caged bird and
once it hit the caged bird the caged
bird started to sing and he left the
window open and adjusted for that reason
and it is not that finding what you have
gone looking for is not pleasing and it
is not even that books being places you
might do that is not a profound and
exciting part of what they are but just
that as a poet the experience of the
unknowable is what excites me and that
might give you a sense why we have ended
up here where they're barely seems to be
a lecture at all for me the closest I
can come to telling seems to be sharing
the idea that one might get up and tell
how things are the way they are or how
things should be the way things should
be seems in a basic way off from my
experience of poetry and it is so easy
to imagine books as the solidifying
process of an otherwise organic poetic
experience containing a mystery more
than being a continually expanding one
but my experience tells me otherwise and
so a purposeful tactical writing feels
odd I want an investigative writing
experience in finding out as part of the
speaking why would I say it if I think I
know it and once I do doesn't that make
me want to question it I thought I know
why I'd say it I'd say
if you asked and I thought one way to
give this lecture would be simply the
stand up here and have you all ask
questions before I talked instead of
after and just answer questions until we
were done I could know a little about
who you are what you want and need
instead of presenting some abstract
relocation of my mind and experience for
your benefit and I thought the thing
about questions that appeals to me is
basically how they express the location
of the questioner so that instead of
talking into a big void of interest and
disapproval it would be more like
talking with a friend and I thought
really what i would do is open up for
questions and whatever the first
question was i would just try and answer
that for an hour using the placement and
concern of that individual to bounce off
of as i talked and as i did the rest of
you could locate us and the
conversations relation to your own
thoughts and concerns there is this
moment in oscar wilde's the decay of
lying when cyril asks vivian if he is
prepared to prove that it is not art
which imitates nature but nature which
imitates art to which vivian replies my
dear fellow i'm prepared to prove
anything i find it charming not because
it expresses some willingness to be
false as much as an interest in the
desire to engage any imaginative
possibility I find when I read him no
but I find when I read him no matter who
is speaking and no matter if the work is
fiction or not I want to attribute the
quote to the author it's part of having
the author there with you when you are
reading and i thought this for a lecture
on books could be a central idea that
application of belief that the word
are the authors those senses feelings
ideas attributed to that author and how
simultaneously we feel we know the
author and the author in a way knows us
I wanted to write about that experience
of the book as an object one carries
around and has with one into one's life
during one's day and how the
accompanying intimate experiences both
of reading and of just holding and
having and being companioned by can
elevate that sense of proximity to the
space of friendship and love and how
simultaneously whatever is living of the
author can unfold and grow and change as
it appears be made as it appears the
realness of these authors is only
difficult when we think about it how
present some value of person seems equal
at times to the flesh and blood ones
that walk around and I don't want it to
be so simplistic I don't believe that
they're the real authors are in full
presenting their spirits encapsulated in
their perfect poems but there may be in
the same way that a gesture might
instantly activate in you an awareness
of a person and express or create some
actual presence of them it is not as
though they try or if they do it is not
as though they're trying really brings
them forth then after they are gone or
while they are away but almost there
being there being in the presence of the
poem seems to have left a residue of
them for you to pick up when you spend
time with the poem too and what is that
spending time by the kind of friendship
Emerson in his essay on friendship talks
about the ability to speak freely and to
be heard one finds comfortably in a
friend
the disposal of inhibition in the face
of acceptance I identify that access of
understanding as the central component
of friendship that it allows one to be
oneself and so when I think about the
way is one might find oneself in
friendship with poets one might find
companionship and understanding not that
what they say makes you know them but
what they say makes you feel with them
or heard by them and it is that
activatable companionship that the book
as an object seems to propose it can
have at times while you are reading it
some aspect of the private letter that
expressive communication which presents
from the outset a belief and interest in
you there is something about the letter
that gets us closer to the idea of the
book and poets not uncommonly send their
poems in letters and so the letter
becomes some reconstruction or almost
publication of what came before it as
the book might later I think of Emily
Dickinson read it resisting the harsh
machinery of publication for the more
intimate opportunities of private
expression she'd send a poem in a letter
and a poem might appear with as much or
as little contextualization as was
desired and a poem became in that moment
of sending it a physical thing that they
might have it in their lives to that it
traveled all the way to them that they
might have it to keep and save to read
and return to I am sending you along
this poem please do not share it with
anyone or I am sending you along this
poem please share with the whole family
I find in experiences of poems shared
this way that kernel of the book it's
making multiple it's making possible
that it can travel and be and stay in
other places that while that might
change the experience of the poem as it
has been private and with the poet alone
it may change that but it doesn't
necessarily diminish it and for the
receiver for the reader that experience
of encounter is the becoming real of
what wasn't there at half past three a
single bird unto a silent sky propounded
but a single term of cautious melody at
half past four experiment had subjugated
test and low her silver principle
supplanted all the rest at half past
seven element nor implement be seen and
place was where the presence was
circumference between and you could read
a letter or a poem over and over again
reawakening the place and experience of
it its impossibility xand complexities
not that having that physical thing in
front of you made it more controlled
just more proximate and alive at half
past three a single bird and to a silent
sky propounded but a single term of
cautious melody at half past four
experiment had subjugated test and low
her silver principle supplanted all the
rest at half past seven element nor
implement be seen and placed was where
the presence was circumference between I
wanted to do a lecture on that repeated
quality we are allowed with recorded
things
one might see something and return to it
in their mind or try and conjure up a
memory but that physical thing is
different not making the poem complete
but accessible the way having a score
for some music allows it to come to be
repeatedly actually and the form of it's
coming to be retaining some obvious and
physical presence a presence that is
reiterated each time it is returned to
but one that feels always in movement
and always different as a living thing
you know to be a particular someone is
different each time you encounter them
and this to me is maybe the core of the
book the poem as a physical object that
it may be and be returned to not that it
is the same but that it is capable of
being again and again that it is capable
of being elsewhere and here that it may
be for one in some fashion similar to
how it is for others and that by being
that way there is a coming together of
people in the beginning of one of his
published journals Jean Cocteau
addresses his readers the unknown
friends enlisted by books and imagines
these friends as his sole excuse for
writing them and reading that sort of
validated my sense that though many of
my friends may not have accepted my
friendship in person there was something
about their impulse not just to write
but to make and share books that
encouraged it later and even his
articulation once shared gets to be mine
as well I can take on his language and I
can be comforted by the support our
similarities imply there is a kind of
book called the commonplace book a
commonplace book was to record and
refine the ideas and
notes and quotations that most
forcefully made themselves a part of
one's life those moments when a
particular thought or expression
answered the question one had struggled
with or made a new question that landed
in one's life with profound meaning and
because most of these were essentially
quotes from others it was important to
have them in a place one could access a
place one could return to not just to
the feeling or even the idea but to the
language of it that there was some
concrete locale to all these
articulations and the book itself and
each one was a kind of companion would
accompany you in the world these were
all things one might return to in
conversation or one my return to and
speaking publicly but for the most part
a commonplace book was a private
storehouse of those points of
understanding that helped a thinking
person move through their life it was a
lifelong endeavor keeping such a book
and one of the ideas for my lecture was
simply to take all the quotes and
anecdotes and lay them down one after
another presenting I guess not only this
span of thoughts and ideas but the
various and exceptional community of
authors I met in books and the books I
met them in the quotes maintain some
energy of the whole they were pulled
from the impossibilities of
understanding their context giving the
sense the enormity of what is out there
so that even done without commentary you
the listeners would be left with some
sort of display of ideas about books and
some greater sense of poets experience
of them as objects made read and found
and as I thought about it I came to
think that the constellation which would
be more appealing would be that of the
books themselves this is
after all a lecture about things made
things in the poem and how it finds its
foreman books and how the books form the
experience of the poem and how the
poetry passes through books as a way to
find some stability and time some
stabilizing moments for them in the
passing of times and lives so it wasn't
even the poems I wanted to get to but
the constellation of forms and I had a
theory my theory was this that interior
two poems are all the various ends they
will never meet inside them partially
those objects they did not become the
vibrant qualities of vibrant things are
often that which they did not contain
the energies of intuitive choice seemed
to me to maintain in themselves at times
the things they didn't choose never
actually having to say no but just a
following of impulses to find a way so
that at any point in a poem the next
word can really be any word at all and
there is some energy of that constant
possibility which I believe the poems
maintained even when they are done kind
of picking the words that are in them
and find themselves all written out and
maybe it goes further than that that
whatever possibilities there are for the
poems those possibilities are left open
are maintained in them as they proceed
towards some eventual home as say in a
book books as form as things can be
present in the poet as a sort of end
space or culmination or object they can
be basically absent from the poet who
focused on the particular poem is not
compelled beyond whatever thing this
it's God books can be an unlikely or
uninteresting destination for poetry or
can be just one of
many interesting destinations that to be
a poet one might write poetry forcefully
towards some end even if that end is not
seen understood or recognized the toward
maybe not even a poem but then there
they are sometimes poems pushing
themselves towards some shared existence
say in a book not even seeing that yet
so to be in that space toward without
the limitations of a goal one can have
in one's mind so many various books that
one can hold at times the deep and
nuanced possibilities without being able
to fix on anyone so that in you there is
this multitude of formal possibility
changing growing presenting itself so
that as a poet the imagined library
provides the landscape in which the
things of what I make are made and this
feels formal that one can hold in
oneself these various formal results and
have in one no exact expectation so my
theory was just that the inside space of
the poet contained and imagined library
and that always changing library created
a private cosmos of formal possibility
there is some aspect of writing poems
that feels like feeling around like a
kind of echolocation and it seems to me
that books are made some way the same
making them from the very beginning one
has the sense of bouncing off and away
from various points recognized and solid
and in these bouncing Zhou fanned away
one finds a trajectory so that while
writing the poems and when I say that I
tend to think of ink and paper already
some sense of the physicality the
continued physicality the eventual
beingness of the made solid place of the
PO
is present that it is to some extent
always present despite there may be
obvious fact that that writing that the
poetry of that moment is unlikely to end
up in that or any other kind of public
forum but that the form of the book is
somehow related to the experience of
making throughout so that the closer the
experience so that the closer to the
experience of the book the more maybe
the physicality does its thing repels
are a track so that that thing that is
to become the book that thing that is to
be the book becomes in a way that has
been happening all along not wittingly
or knowingly but has been present the
physical aspects of the book are present
all the time in the form of the imagined
library those varied spaces that the
poems occupy in the moments of writing
them during the spans of time of writing
them are related to the things that they
become and while I don't imagine that
the central location of poetry is the
book really no I imagine the central
location of poetry is the world the
human world in which language is shared
kept in all sorts of ways I think of the
book as a constantly present and capable
continuation of the acts of making
poetry and here I've gone and given you
my theory without explaining a central
part pages papers letters manuscripts
alive inside of it experiences of the
making mimicked and how it's made to say
it seem simplistic but I will give it a
try there are all different kinds of
books of poetry that's it there are all
different kinds of books of poetry not
that there are all different kinds of
poetry that end up in books which I
think of as the more common sense of it
but that unlike most other forms of
writing poetry shoves nudges and creates
its own spaces and the only way I
imagined to really express this and the
only way I imagined to express that
cosmos of formal possibility would be to
describe hundreds of books hundreds and
hundreds of books not their poems
exactly but their forms in the forms
they came to have because of their
poetry that it seemed to me was the most
obvious idea for a lecture on books to
display some part of my cosmos what is
it that I bounce off of and so I started
to list and describe books made
privately and given us gifts the book
made from a diary that has the big
present face of the author on its cover
the book of fragments gathered by one's
family the pink page book with its
musical notations or the enormous book
that expresses with its size the nature
and depth the vastness of its endeavour
the thin narrow book with its thin
narrow poems but the more I started to
list and describe the more abstract they
seems which makes sense when I'm not
thinking about them that's exactly what
they are abstract presence of meaningful
things but here we are actually thinking
and talking about them so that I want to
go deeper I want to describe them more
the form of the book built around itself
so that when I'm describing a book of
short fragmentary poems I can say there
they are on their big white pages the
space around them expressing time are
making quiet the quiet and time around
them elevating in them elevating them in
some way or making the ink and presence
of words more solid and the experience
of that page after page or touch of the
paper when you've been looking mostly at
it the physical qualities of sparseness
and even that didn't work look how
removed from its person it is what poems
are they who is the author where is this
book so I guess we've come all the way
around and maybe the only way to do this
is not to describe the imagined cosmos
but to introduce a single point in it
described a single book described the
life of a single book over here the tree
growing that the paper will come from
and over here the poetry starting to
form in the person or in the family of
the person as the person is forming and
then the poems over time happening and
finding their form while the sources of
need and want around the poet grow
drawing the poem out into the public
world and the ways that object comes to
be and then following just one of them
just one book out to its recipient and
the life that person has with it reading
it scribbling in its margins speaking
its poems aloud or leaving it quietly on
the shelf yes I thought that's the
lecture I should give
you